the mood in Puerto Rico is shifting from
celebration to uncertainty over who will
replace the embattled governor he is set
to step down on Friday the Justice
Secretary who is next in the line of
succession tweeted yesterday quote I
have no interest in occupying the
position David beg no is just back from
covering the political crisis there in
Puerto Rico quite the tweet there what's
next well look it's turning out to be a
political soap opera quite frankly I
mean so you've got you've got a line of
succession right that clearly lays out
who will become the next governor but
now that you've got the woman who's the
Justice Secretary who's next in line
saying hey I don't want it the question
is who's next all while people are
standing in the streets right now saying
we will continue to protest there was
dancing in the streets of San Juan
Sunday to celebrate the fact that the
scandal-plagued governor Ricardo Rocio
will be stepping down on Friday but
after two weeks of demonstrations to
oust him new protests broke out
overnight to demand the resignation of
Juan de Vasquez
she is the Secretary of Justice who is
next in line to take the governor's
place law professor Carlos Ramos I think
the population believed that she is the
political system is a matter of trust
necesita the fact that Vasquez says she
doesn't even want the job he's throwing
the line of succession into chaos if the
governor resigns the territory's
Secretary of State should have been next
in line but he resigned earlier in the
month caught up in the same scandal
involving offensive chat messages as the
governor next is Vasquez if she doesn't
take the office it will fall to the
Secretary of the Treasury
but he's only 31 years old and you have
to be 35 to become governor then it
falls to the Secretary of Education
who's only been on the job a few months
Vasquez is calling on the current
governor to appoint a new
second-in-command before Friday making
her succession a moot point
we asked Vasquez on Twitter do you plan
to resign in order to not be
constitutionally obligated to assume the
governor's office she has not yet
responded if she does not step down she
is obligated to sir
so David do you think the Secretary of
Justice is saying she's not interested
in the job but remaining and then will
ultimately say it's my duty I'm gonna
take the job look I think she knows
she's up against the head win of those
protesters who said they'll remove the
governor and they were successful in 12
days here are the options she could take
over real quickly appoint in number two
then resigned and the number two takes
over or the governor over the next five
days could name and number to basically
give her room to walk out and the new
number two could step in it's really
chaos there right now and the governor
has not said a word about what he's
going to do could he go back on his
resignation and not resign yeah possible
if any in this point in Puerto Rico
anything is possible and really tough
for all the people who live there living
through all this I'm sure we'll be
sending you back there David thank you